ça tombe bien il est l'agent tournoi
non non non non non qu'est ce que c'est
que ces histoires tournée oui par
rapport à un modèle terriens
contrairement à ma légende
voilà mesdames et messieurs vous
n'assistez 1 c'est extrêmement important
ce qui s'est passé hier soir c'est le
deuxième scoop de la soirée patrick
bruel va se marier et jean claude moly
embrasse les filles avant d'embrasser
les garçons qu'elle sait faire des
tonnes non ah bon sa branche d'arbre à
ses épaules oui en même temps c'était
pas très compromettants je dois dire oui
mais attend que ce c'est compromettant
je trouve qu'elle est très très joli et
si tout est fait comme ça il y aurait
pas beaucoup de pdg en train de 17,8 il
serait bientôt expliqué qu'il avait que
des tons quoi ouais en fait c'est ça
donc j'en veux briller en ce moment vous
êtes souvent à rome où vous tournez
concurrence déloyale d'ettore scola avec
gérard depardieu c'est ça et tout près
et puis en fait c'est aussi souvent à
paris pour faire la promo de votre livre
oui enfin pour rencontrer
vraiment batterie et chantal voyage
seshoka le vih est un hommage en fait on
peut le dire aujourd'hui c'est un
hommage surtout que j'ai connu aussi l
aube a alors ça s'appelle le ruisseau
des singes
alors on bruce j'explique à votre place
parce que j'avais tellement répété que
le gall et donc le ruisseau des singes
parce que vous étiez petit vous avez
j'étais petit aussi voilà plus de
cinquante lui c'est cette même scène
vous souhaitez blida la voilà si une
soirée on aurait pu se rencontrer parce
que tu es né il ya pas longtemps toi là
c'est une soirée souvenirs souvent des
de chercher à l'école sera accompagnée
et serait appris des trucs pour moi je
vais bien sorti mais quelle est donc la
promenade familiale
on a fait comprendre à l'agent en
calèche tous les deux ans guy au maroc
c'est au maroc c'est moi qui conduis et
je vais la tête énorme que des scoops
et alors la promenade familiale du
dimanche se faisait à un endroit et ça
fait les gorges de la chiffa y avait des
petits singes moyenne avait mis à peu
près de toutes les couleurs les singes
en liberté est mieux que disneyland
parce qu'ils venaient manger des bananes
voilà wet est alors pour atteindre cet
éden il y avait 40 km d'en faire parce
que vous étiez malade en voiture c'est
une traction avant sa santé les sens
c'est 1900 temps de la faction à nouveau
me sied voila voila je rendais la
rendait l'âme et jaune un peu une espèce
de l'image comme ça j'ai pensé pour
arriver au bonheur au paradis il faut
passer des obstacles des obstacles du
genre thierry ardisson c'est une
métaphore c'est une métaphore de la vie
ce titre alors oui justement dans les
choses désagréables avant d'atteindre le
bonheur via vos parents un parce que
c'est vrai que de l'agréable ils n'ont
rien compris l'on est membre et votre
père était militaire et il acceptait mal
déjà que vous fassiez le singe votre
mère qui vous disaient surtout te fait
pas remarquer alors quoi pour vous
connaissez risque d'être difficile
c'était comme dira mozart fait pas de
musique un peu quoi c'est gentil ça
ouais c'est gentil
musiciens et deux frères donc non mais
comme j'ai vu la légère
vous avez la légion d'honneur 80 votre
mère lui est content de sa mère sais
c'est pas du style à votre mère elle dit
autre façon de nos jours il a donné à
tout le monde ce qui est vrai un peu ce
qu un peu vrai mais en même temps
j'étais pas très aimable lorsque mon
fils et moi je joue au théâtre elle
disait que le partenaire été formidable
mais la fille était magnifique
d'ailleurs c'était de former ainsi pour
ma mère c'est sympa donc deux ils
commencent par votre enfant
fils de militaire de casernes en caserne
à vous êtes né dans une caserne fait un
essai à brière de choses près c'est sa
venue en métropole marseille histoire
projet oui semblait oui voilà alors là
votre père évidemment lui c'était un
militaire qu'est ce qu'il a fait pendant
la guerre lui laissait bien comportée
votre père oui c'est bien comporté ces
schémas ou ont balancé par an une
attitude un peu je vous le dis à ta il a
eu une attitude un peu tiède dans la
gueule non ils étaient tièdes comme je
vous signale que 58 en france eh oui il
était militaire le maréchal pétain le
vainqueur de verdun
il pouvait pas penser qu'ils pourraient
aller quelque chose de trop mal dont il
était un petit peu obéissant voilà je
lui ai reproché sa dette d'avoir aidé
troupeau obéissant
vous savez il ya une phrase de vous
dites que je fais toutes les citations
toujours oui mais jusqu'à maintenant je
n'ai pas fait une seule salle s'est
largement fait rue littré tristan
bernard protestant bernard g disaient
ils croient qu'ils sont heureux parce
qu'ils sont immobiles et j'ai reproché à
mon père et à beaucoup de français moi
j'avais 8 ans d'être immobile alors il a
peut-être pas entendu le général de
gaulle mais il était resté un peu
tranquille
1 et je trouve que dans la vie il faut
oser même si on se trompe oui et alors
citation pour citations c'est d'ailleurs
marqué au début de votre bouquin c'est
jeu j'écris mes mémoires avant de ne
plus en avoir
voilà bah oui on est un peu vieux on a
des rancunes des rangs des standards
mais il vaut mieux être généreux alors
en 46 bon la guerre est finie vous vous
retrouvez au prytanée militaire de la
flèche et nicole d'enfants de troupe
vous aviez une photo d'ailleurs j'étais
en unissant les ont soulevé à 5h le
matin vous elle lit au carré on a stick
et
autant de wichita pas connu tout ça pas
mal avec regardes tu m'écoutes ben voilà
il c'est là où j'ai découvert le métier
pas ding ding boum boum l'amour l'amitié
la menace quelques jours et 5 heures du
matin le multi qui distille quelques
heures du matin ça c'est chic c'est même
déjà tombés sur la chaussée de travail
ça va commencer parce que et pas même à
cravate
non si elle est bien sa cravate et l'on
attend ses études à leur mère décrite
alors 30 ans sa mère sa cravate dans
jean claude brialy sortir quand il ya
une cravate qui ne me plaît pas je ne me
dîtes filets des années qu'on est
ensemble le matin quand il parlait d'une
carotte qui me plaît pas avoir un bon
copain jacques brillet
bon alors vous êtes donc au prytanée
militaire et vous aller en vacances à
paris ainsi votre oncle et votre tante
qui vous allez devoir joséphine baker
j'aime une tante qui était très gentil
pas de jeux de groupe
la soeur de ma mère qui était une femme
très sympathique parce que elle qu'elle
avait compris elle est ce que j'adore
hitler
et grâce à elle j'ai pu voir des images
qui ne saurait c'est toute ma vie
et oui et vous découvrez le théâtre donc
avec à baden oui oui d'abord là et
cabris en fait en 46 sabadell avec le
fils du consul général de france
oui qu'ils étaient fiancés ça s'est bien
fait d'arrêter les côtés et là vous
rencontrer et dit je fais hier et jean
marais ont tourné à la baleine et vous
rencontrer pierre l'homme qui est un
opérateur assez connus très importants
faisant nôtre en faisant votre service
il a fêté hier pierre lhomme philippe de
broca et robert aux les du pot toute
votre vie vous avez du pauvre et oui
j'ai toujours rencontré les gens qui
s'agitent à coucher beaucoup
contrairement à quoi et alors quand vous
êtes démobilisés vous allez à paris avec
vous avez fini votre service mes gars
vous a dit pour faire le service
quand vous avez fini vous allez à paris
oui hélas alors ce même esprit que mon
cd avec une seule des 26 francs par jour
vous êtes arrivé à économiser 60 mille
francs prix je n'ai pas sérieux ça vient
de notre mère ça votre côté bas de laine
comme ça pas madeleine je n'aime pas je
trouve que j'aime pas du tout du mépris
pour l'argent mais je n'aime pas le
gaspiller votre petite maison 18e la
petit château bleu est très très jeune
abane 3 à 23 ans donc j'avais un côté
quand même vous attendez à avoir une
maison à 23 ans parce qu'on a travaillé
simplement ma mère m'a dit quand
j'allume ma maison il m'a dit mais tu as
besoin de ça pour toi tout seul oui
j'étais content d'avoir une maison est
ce que j'irai vais tout mais regardez
par exemple au cimetière acheté une
concession
non attendez vous acheter une concession
cimetière une première concession à côté
de nos missions a coûté la vie en
acheter une autre
non mais c'est comme les discours
politiques quand on veut couper dans la
phrase on peut arranger vous achetez
bruxelles par session j'ai je me
sentirai non
ces femmes dont j'espère comptera quatre
a assez pour ça assez pour mettre des
copains de concession vous j'ai pas une
toute concession c'est un petit peu plus
grand que d'habitude
la troupe s'est ajoutée la dame aux
camélias côtés de marie dupuis l'inversé
les jours de grande race ils seraient
des soirées que je sais faire que même
même sa tombe est chouette quoi comme
alors vous dites les gens du cahier la
bande des cahiers du cinéma
quand vous étiez à paris au début ce
soit 55 56
oui ils vous payez votre place au cinéma
chez vous des rires nous laisse dire oui
alors ciment cette idée vous êtes
toujours fait rire les gens présents
place étant vous taper la tête contre
les murs si ça faisait rire les gens là
j'étais très content mais bon si ça fait
rire les jeunes faisaient mal de sectra
ordinaire que maintenant je me fais plus
malin si c'est pas difficile d'être sens
à la représentation de vouloir séduire
d'être aimé de j'avais pas ça chez moi
ne me comprenait pas donc je voulais
père à l'extérieur et comme je suis
joyeux séduisait déco pac et j'ai
compris le rire c'était la première
séduction une femme vous dira toujours
un homme qui me fait rire las pour elle
la lie tout à l'heure en parlant de son
copain quelqu'un qui vous fait rire son
copain éléments york en même temps oui
mais l'affairé de new york
alors donc votre sac à la vie elle
allait calibrer bruel zazie
oui on allait mieux c'est clair
secret bonne secrets vont vous faire des
nouveaux merveilleux amis que vous avez
cédé avoir fait rire
d'abord je crois que j'étais gentil je
faisais rire et je partais quand il
fallait et je ne demandais rien en âme
et il faut jamais rien de moins comme ça
on vous donne alors votre bouquin bon il
faut le dire un truc je vais pas
raconter ses 450 places
oui bon il est donc assez marrant a
quand même il ya de longs oui vous fait
le pitre toujours vous fait rire au
festival de cannes pour devenir copains
et quoi a été beau ah oui ça veut dire
que quand je vois des jeunes premiers
d'aujourd'hui est très beau je regarde
pas alors là il n'y a pas photo y'a pas
photo dans la cause de cette anecdote
qui est assez rigolote donc vous devenez
copain avec lui au festival de cannes
pour monter à paris à l'époque il vit
avec brigitte aubert a surpris ce qui
était des rendez-vous juillet de jacques
becker il faut le signaler c'est pas un
soir vous dînez tous les trois elle m'a
juste dit on sort oui bon et d'histoire
tu viens pas il dit oui nos nichons avec
mon copain on va faire un petit un petit
tour elle dit mais moi je n'entends tu
restes à la maison tranquille sympa mais
bon j'en connais d'autres avouent façade
avec vous même ah oui ils ont cru bon
d'accord tous les cas il fait ça et puis
il a demandé que la voiture elle ne peut
pas lui donner parce que des bus que tu
veux sortir ripon copa va à pied
ouais alors il sort un revolver en or
embouchant vers les coûts non mais
attends un peu de foi enfin le sourire
comme à bombay pour m'impressionner il
voulait faire gary cooper pour moi très
bon et puis après il met à deux filles
il fait pas très fier non il tire dans
la serrure de la bannière les quarts
plein oui oui mais les deux chiens tout
ça sera la première fois qu'il le
faisait oui oui c'est donnant donnant
d'abord parce que j'entends quand tu
gagnes tu veux faire une biographie de
vie pour raconter tout ça il interdit en
même temps vous vous en a pas non non
pas du tout raconte des conneries quand
tu auras cours des méchancetés et des
trucs moi j'ai vécu deux ans avec lui
quand j'entends aujourd'hui qu'on dise
pour un verre de whisky on pouvait avoir
de longues c'était vrai se trouve ça ne
c'est pas vrai absolument pas vrai les
papas compte trois bouteilles de gens
parce que j'allais dire lorsque j'allais
dire de verre mais je prête à vous alors
vous raconter que l'on aime pour une bd
du chalet accueillir michener d'air donc
parole on demande de venir bas également
évident et là vous assister à la
naissance d'une passion entre les deux
un coup de foudre
j'en ai crise dans les deux mois et
alors le soir sur les colos ça vous
allez au lido tous les trois de long il
prend des langoustes du champagne
il voulait épater encore plus
mademoiselle schneider d'abord qu'il
n'avait pas besoin de ça allait déjà
tombés dans le piège
elle avait plongé dans ses grands yeux
bleus et il dit ont valu de aussi
battant na pas rond il défendra au lido
bon tu es toi bon alors on va au lido on
va falloir de table il connaissait
directeur on à la table du milieu on
nous amène caviar foie gras tout ça moi
j'étais angoissé fils de militaire un
peu comme ça j'ai on va passer deux mois
faire la vaisselle
ça va ça va être terrible violent quand
on m'apportait reddition comme on va
faire rage et et transpirer jeu pour eux
il était heureux amoureux il se regarde
et il buvait du champagne ça la musique
y dansait moi c'est comme un conte
j'attendais la sédition toute la soirée
et puis à minuit minuit et demi le
spectacle est terminé
l'orchestré gentil fait une valse pour
robbie parce que vous mettez une star
internationale et on lui joue l'aval de
6,6 elle se lève de l'empa avec lé voilà
qui dansent les deux et moi je me suis
là terrorisée et bien un truc qui arrive
le maître d'hôtel à aimer mais
l'addition devant les yeux à moi alors
je vois la mission c'était 4035 migrants
c'était épouvantable pour moi c'était
six mois de salaire veulent bon je dis
bon oui tout de suite tout de suite ça
se prend un air d'un dollar revient
jeudi
je glisse l'addition discrètement parce
qu'on est avec une dame il regarde et
dit alors la magie alors quoi et bien
alors on m'y a compris le manège a pris
l'addition à la signer c'est elle qui
nous invitait le soir j'espère que la
gambie sûrement à part ça il faisait
pâle figure donc une copine jamais alors
edith piaf auriez eu un truc ici un soir
patrick sébastien nous a raconté que
chaque fois qu'il mettait une cassette
de piaf dans sa mercedes
il avait un accident et quelqu'un a
parlé de vous en disant mais jean claude
brialy
il a hérité de la petite robe noire de
de pia est la première fois qu il a
voulu la montrer à quelqu'un la petite
robe noire de piaf
le téléphone a sonné hop c'était pierre
brasseur qui était mort oui la deuxième
fois qu'il la menthe le téléphone sonne
ap c'était au sahara pau le dernier
jules de piac était mort donc j'ai
retrouvé sa place dans l'hôtellerie dite
était quelqu'un des cas une présence si
fort à metz et fort que je pense qu'elle
veut pas qu'on emmerde
elle est contente qu'on l'entend de
chanter encore 35 ans après sa mort et
d'entendre cette voix unique et ses
chansons d'amour mais elle était très
superstitieuse et je crois qu'elle n'est
pas contente quand on touche à sa vie
privée ou à des choses personnelles bien
quand on n'a fait que deux louches
le cdt marcel bon j'avais dit à claude
tu es sûr que il m'a dit oui moi j'ai le
ventre et piaf elle était contente qu'on
va sa vie et puis c'est vrai que le
premier jour de
et c'est patrick dewaere ce suicide l'ap
qui devait jouer celle ci doit donc tout
d'un coup il ya une pression dans le
film est le fils n'a pas très bien
marché alors qu'il était très bien fait
et qui est d'une brique c'était
formidable
mais sa part marché bon théo sarapo que
je connaissais avec est dit est dit
m'avait dit si c'est que je meurs tu
t'occupes de théo tout le monde à
laisser tomber ce qui a été fait
d'ailleurs dès qu'elle est morte
donc j'ai appelé théo jeudi vient chez
moi dans ma belle maison pour passer 15
jours ou trois semaines peut être
tranquille pas avoir la pression de la
presse des photos pour me remercier m'a
offert des livres
et puis la petite une d une des petites
robes avec quatre groupes de scène de
desdites avec le petit coeur comme ça
c'était alors j'ai mis la za carton avec
du papier de soie et puis j'ai jamais je
suis pas fétichiste je n'aime pas voir
là la robe desdites la nuit etc
un jour c'est vrai des amis m'ont parlé
des dykes m'ont parlé de pierre brasseur
en disant j'ai toujours bourré c'est un
conte fait rage des furieux parce que
j'adore les pires brasseur et je dis je
vais vous montrer là il est ami à qui
les piafs content des amis à qui les
gaffes c'est un honneur dont je vais
vous montrer la robe de scène d'édith au
moment où je monte pour la chercher le
téléphone sonne mal à pierre venait de
mourir je vais pas deux ans plus tard la
même chose et c'était ou qui venaient se
tue en voiture
et voilà la robe et voilà alors bon donc
votre bouquin regorge d'histoires comme
ça qu'ils sont qui soit si long de
l'année un record ge record je sais bien
que comme serveuse gorge et d'histoire
comme ça mais c'est vrai il ya plein
d'éléments c'est tous des gens qu'on a
connus lino ventura qui parlait trop bas
les les ingé son aigle et arletty qui
voulait plus dire atmosphère atmosphère
parce que disait le public le dit mieux
que moi c'est vrai elle meurt dans la
misère a fait quand elle est morte on
découvre je paye un tableau du trio
segonzac pas le mieux c'est jules berry
ah oui à jbeil formidable gilbert il
avait une une chambre de bonne qui
montrait aux huissiers il habitait au
genre je me tue à monsieur monsieur
andreck était un type extraordinaire
très élégant qui étaient calmes et le
deauville normandie
tout laissait tout à la suite de
barrières bon ils avaient tous ses
hôtels ses casinos ils étaient très
riches mais les mets les artistes et
jules berry joue au casino tout en
anglais avaient dû pas beaucoup au
casino de deauville au casino de cannes
ou alors donc il avait une grande amitié
pour
et ils lui avaient donné une suite alan
à la vie au george sa cassette et son
hôtel et il avait une petite chambre de
bonne pour les huissiers se donner ainsi
arriver en disant monsieur berry il
habite là-bas au 9e étage or moi j'ai
envoyé à l'ipcc en un centre vide
et puis rien donc il pouvait rien saisir
et le taux élevé du champagne et veolia
a montré très charmant de marcel andré
et de jb à jour je berry envoie un
télégramme à monsieur andré à deauville
reluisant envoie-moi urgent 5000 francs
je le dirai à tout le monde et monsieur
et monsieur andré a dit voilà 500 francs
ne le dis à personne agissant comme ça
c'est un petit peu comme si vous
habitiez gentilhommerie a dîné avec un
peu mis de ma voix vous acheté il ya un
petit problème simplement c'est que vous
parlez de tout le monde vous parlait
très peu de vous dans ce bouquin il faut
attendre la page 414 sur 450 pour vous
évoquiez votre homosexualité alors que
c'est un truc que tout le monde connaît
bien ce programme étalé je m'en fous
complètement j'ai pas une étoile rose
ici je prends là vous parler du racisme
et tout ça je pense que quand il ya de
l'amour coux soit m'a donné cette porte
pas un jugement d'honneur je dis
simplement la home ou sexuellement sa
jeudi s'arrête sur mana jeudi sable je
m'en fous je le sais et vous attendez la
page 414 pour évoquer non c'est pas
vraiment mon éditeur qui monsieur fixot
way m'a dit mais tu parle jamais de ta
vie privée gidon d'ailleurs j'ai fait
une page blanche
ce qu'il aurait fallu à lire mon cher
pour affronter tout d abord alors j'ai
donc mis une page blanche a aimé ce que
j'ai croisé un ma vie je je les salue
mais ils peuvent à ce que chacun leur
nom ouais il souhaiterait un jour un
livre tout cas beaucoup de filles dans
votre vie comment ménager étaient
bilingues mon cher
et puis c'est vrai d'avoir d'abord quand
je suis arrivé à paris j'ai tombé
amoureux des mots tout n'aurait pu
penser que c'était des gens marais bon
j'ai rencontré dans la vie va garder
avait présenté l'intrus faut absolument
qu'elle reste mon amie et ma marraine de
théâtre bien